you know damn well they didn't care for
it I communicated honestly for everyone
who thinks I'm not honest I want to tell
you guys something really quick I am so
honest that I rejected an opportunity to
go meet em night Shyamalan at a glass
junket ice flat-out told them I love the
opportunity to go all the way to
Philadelphia that you guys are gonna pay
for all this set me up with a hotel
everything they were gonna set up and I
had to say I really admire the
opportunity the fact of the matter is I
don't like that movie and I feel like
you guys should probably use someone who
is more positive about the film it's
just that simple but all these people
who say like Disney paid you you're in
your pocket or you want to just keep
going to press screenings have you guys
seen the like there are movies we
haven't recommend don't don't even just
go off of us many people who haven't
recommended Marvel related films Disney
related films people who are coded 20th
Century Fox screenings Warner Brothers
screenings that we don't go to have
often given them negative reviews and
consistently still get invited to the
screenings
there's an old principle they used to
say that there's no such thing as bad
press and if people be talking about the
movie that's just more attention going
on that movie so yeah while every studio
wants a good review just because you
give them a bad one doesn't mean they're
going to ban you from doing that and I
think both of our goals with these
videos is to figure out an authentic
depiction of how we felt about each
movie and to just share that with you
guys and if you don't want to have that
opinion you just don't have to watch the
video
hey there reject nation I'm Greg Alva
I'm John Humphrey so we just uploaded a
Captain Marvel spoiler talk Joshua left
it's had never centered we know that
there's a lot of those hate comments a
controversy on our non-spoiler review
imagine if we go off our spoiler yeah
because basically we didn't hate Captain
Marvel no in fact I quite liked it and I
was more in the middle ground on my
non-spoiler review I was like I think
it's funny I think it's really
entertaining that the action the visuals
are cool brie Larson I had a lot of
issues with her performance and liked
him more than basically in this water
view I liked him more the second time
around but I still had certain issues
with it I know that there's a lot of
politics surrounding this film but we
did our best to keep that to a minimal
and our spoiler talk so we could save as
much for this so we're gonna do is we're
gonna react to some of the comments and
go over some of them oh you haven't seen
all of them haven't looked at them for a
couple days ya know you know because a
lot of people came out to give their
opinion before they even watch the movie
a lot of emotions I'll just say a couple
things really quick if you're not
open-minded to hearing what we got to
say or if you're not open-minded to
having a respectful disagreement mmm
good luck being here two things I want
to talk about really quick before we hop
into this politics in movies and
feminism in general politics and movies
but I often hear after you know talking
doing YouTube for a while it's people
are constantly saying stuff like I don't
want politics in my movies I don't want
political point of views in my movies or
in my entertainment or whatever you know
people often say that and to if you feel
that way I hate to break it to you
that's never gonna change
it's never going to change because it's
been a part of the landscape of cinema
for as long as I can recall whether it's
done in a very in-your-face kind of way
or in a more subtle approach it's always
been there it's gonna remain that way
look at the eras of most of our films
usually it's a reflection of the
political landscape nicely political I
don't mean government I don't mean the
White House I don't mean Republican
versus Democrat
or something like that political can
mean the people political kameen society
political is culture anything that
touches upon a relevant issue or some
kind of movement happening now yes and
it's you know as much as yeah you can
feel those things are intrusive
sometimes those interpretations exist
whether the person who authored the work
wanted them to be there or not there are
a lot of movies that you can read
subtext into just because we're all part
of the world and inevitably that's in
everybody's subconscious yeah and it's
been a part of comic book movies for a
long time too you can draw kinds of
political interpretations out of comic
book movies and some of them are quite
fascist I think about the Dark Knight
that dealt a lot with surveillance
issues with arson and that's a political
thing patriot act going on yeah look at
the MCU for example the very first MCU
movie very political Iron Man he starts
off in the war realizes that he is
farming yeah like it's tears of
terrorism roofs of arms dealing
tough materials of weapons of mass
destruction yeah and he's realizing that
oh I made these weapons for one purpose
but that doesn't mean they're not gonna
fall into the wrong hands it's very
relevant about violence for profit and
then look at the one before Captain
Marvel Avengers infinity war Thanos is
motivation the idea of scarcity in this
world had populate overpopulation these
these are also political things as well
heck look at Black Panther like we're
close ourselves up like rap that had a
similar type of backlash because you'd
be a fool to think all three of those
Captain America movies don't have a
political agenda in there the reason is
are you part of the reason anyway we
have civil war at least now in the movie
landscape is as a reaction to some of
the political subtext you can draw out
of comic book films they bother yeah
have the debate about what is ethical
here in a time where we have a
government in a society and people with
these abilities it touches the work so
movies for the longest time and it's
never going to stop will always have
some kind of political thing in there so
when I think about feminism and first
off feminism does not mean
men suck woman should be on top that's
not what it means
feminism is about equality of the sexes
that's what it's about equality beyond
the sexes I mean like at least as they
taught it to us in school feminism
truthfully is about equal opportunity
for everybody whether you're man woman
whether you're of a different creed or
sexuality or age or physical ability you
know it's about equality for everyone
the way how the entertainment industry
in general is approached is through
political reaction yeah it's a big part
what makes art so impactful and just
because you're being political doesn't
necessarily mean you're being deep
because there are so many especially
nowadays there's so many like kind of
mindless pg-13 action movies the Apes so
much imagery feeling tone out of the
news how many scenes in a desert of like
terrorist operations have you seen in
recent movies that all feel very kind of
jarring and real or when I watch Aquaman
and orms all about ah you're polluting
the ocean and environmental issues like
this is this is all it's all there
when I hear that Captain Marvel has a
bit of a feminist agenda to push or to
put upfront on display or to talk about
that doesn't turn me off I appreciate
you being forward about that it's one
thing to say I don't mind a feminist
angle in this movie what I don't like is
poor storytelling poor writing over all
that it sacrifices good moviemaking to
push a message that is one completely
different argument as opposed to I hear
feminism's in this no no no yeah not on
my watch that's a whole different debate
guys if you're that person will plain
and simple we're not gonna be friends if
you're subscribed you might want to
unsubscribe right away yeah I all
encourage you to do that it's that Kurt
Cobain quote if you're against you know
the homosexuals the ladies anybody else
just just don't [ __ ] with us just don't
bother with us we don't want you that's
pretty much it it's one thing to have
issues with the way a story is handled
and I hear feminism's like that's a
thing that put a female empowerment I'm
okay with knowing that's in here I'm
okay
even knowing that's part of its subtext
it's all about how it's handled alright
that's what I'll go with that and that's
not the only relevant political subtext
in the film there's a whole at least
approach to the allegory of the refugee
situation in the world that's a big part
of the plot of the movie actually yeah
and I know a lot of people are also
attacking this movie because of brie
Larson that comment she's made in the
past which probably find a comment that
allow us to riff off of it long story
short I've seen the headlines be really
selective and then twisted into their
own language and then reveal the actual
quotes brie Larson is killed she's
wearing their ears as a necklace
hey let's let's pull up these comments
to get to it hooray all right so as of
filming this fifty seven thousand views
1854 likes 904 dislikes oh yeah let's go
through the top comments it was actually
a lot of positive comments it's kind of
funny there is a fair mixture yeah we're
just going for the fun one for this
video there's a lot of positive comments
in here actually what I've noticed about
this comment section is the people are
trying to find any logical reason to
explain away the fact that we could have
positive things to say about this movie
as if it's impossible just to have a
positive thing to say about this movie
there's so many comments to the tune of
you're just trying to agree with your
female guests because you want her to
have sex yeah or something from Paul
Parker this sounds so much like to geeks
agreeing with the hot chick in hope she
will pick one to go out with just saying
I'm gonna say this right now because
John's right about that people have said
that like we were afraid to like rip on
this movie because we had a woman with
us well that's just not the game
honestly Stacy Howard's a really good
friend of ours he's a really good an
actual friend of ours not once have we
talked about any of the politics
surrounding or the debate surrounding
this movie off camera or on camera its
Stacy I feel comfortable enough to say
whatever the [ __ ] I want around Stacy
if there's anything here about like not
wanting to upset her
Stacy can have no wish to have no
quarrel with her
I would are you grown more than happy to
disagree with her on that of course your
female friend is defending the movie
because she is a feminist if you are not
a feminist and you are a sexist you
understand what that means there Brett
the saint it means you are sexist
there's no various sexist comment of
course you're a feminist you're a woman
I like Christie be Thomas is coming
today Greg reminds me of Joey Tribbiani
and friends with the Capri tries to be a
young cool guy lol sup dude it's wack
with the beanie
I remember that episode there was a
season 7 episode 1 well I know friends
it's really sad watching this you
couldn't even make a parody this cringe
this is the the sentiment that just
keeps popping up that bugs me the most
is that people won't even entertain the
idea who I even show up in a comment
thread if you're just going to dismiss
the possibility of somebody else's
opinion a movie like this alright Sean
take it away with DB tidings he says
quoting John if you tell me I'll care
arguing the stupidest critique you've
ever heard the guy who is overly
critical of almost every movie that is
non Marvel I have been critical of
Marvel movies like the one we're on Mike
I'm the one who's like on it he's like
well movies are not my quote sham if
eclis I like a lot of them but it's not
my favorite kind of movie should be
carefully the personality and conflict
of Captain Marvel rather than being
shown through good acting such a white
knight shaking my head yeah um I guess
this is I would have to go back and see
where I actually said that I feel like
this is a semantic thing what I meant
was if you demonstrated more of those
moments I'm not saying you need to tell
it to me I'm a fan of visual
storytelling actually so
I really don't know what you want from
me I mean if you give me the context in
any way shape or form
I might care a bit more that's with them
virtual 2000 says don't be shills guys
singing at a great time with it is not
match up with general consensus refer
screen joke is for a way more balanced
review dude it doesn't have to it
doesn't have like literally you don't
have to have the same opinion as
everybody you don't that doesn't make
you a screen junkies they don't like
elite a battle angel and Aquaman do you
or would you say the same thing for them
your comment literally says you saying
you had a great time with it is not
matching up with the general consensus
so go listen to a review that matches
with the general consensus there's not
allowed to be a spectrum yeah most of
all be the same opinions I'm very
black-and-white thinking you got going
on there let me let me clear something
up right now I have absolutely nothing
to gain from liking or recommending this
movie in any way shape or form I just
happened to have liked to the movie
Mathieu V Hanson some of the most
perfectly balanced reviews of the films
to YouTube Dennis would be proud thanks
buddy 311 Mikey says guys no one cares
about your pronounce whatever you put
the actual reveal all the spoilers just
made me leave the channel basically no
one cares bro three one one Mikey so
many movie review channels must have
really upset you by putting up their
non-spoiler reviews you dumbass it's
customary before the film is out to wait
it's to get upset about something pretty
common and also expected purple shadow
509 people dislike this video because
solely because you like this movie she
said a single sentence which was
misinterpreted is that hard for you do
some research to the actual interview
and see what she said it shouldn't
influence your entire opinion on the
movie not actually glad you brought this
up purple shadow well they're
non-spoiler review I said I didn't
follow any of what she actually said all
I saw were a couple of headlines and I'm
sure there was more to the context I'm
pretty sure that's what I said the nice
thoughts blow everyone I'm like so I
have none of this preconceived notion or
anything about brie Larson opinion to go
off of so after getting all these
dislikes and comments I decided to like
look it up I found so many things that
were quoting the exact same [ __ ] but the
funny thing was they all have the same
twisted headlines they all have the same
quotes same quotes in the articles but
the headlines were all like brie Larson
hates white men white day why she
doesn't want white people to see her
that is way taking it out of context
very much extremely so people are
running with that cuz they're there at
least one or two comments in this
threads somewhere where people flat out
said like no she said she hates white
men that's not at all what she said not
at all I'm gonna just quote it right now
so everyone has it right here and you
could look it up yourself on the same
headlines that say she hates white men
that'll have these exact quotes
audiences are not allowed enough chances
to Republic discourse on these films are
the people that the films were made for
I do not need a 40-year old white dude
to tell me what didn't work for him
about a wrinkle in time it wasn't made
for him I want to know what I meant to
women of color to biracial woman to teen
women of color to teens that are
biracial am I saying I hate white dudes
no I'm not but if you make the movie
that is a love letter to women of color
there's an insanely low chance a woman
of color will have a chance to see your
movie and review your movie I'm looking
for is to bring more seats to the table
no one is getting their chair taken away
there's not less seats at the table
there's just more seats at the table
about a year ago I started paying
attention what my press days look like
in the critics reviewing movies and I
and notice it appears to be
overwhelmingly white male so I spoke to
dr. Stacy Smith at USC Annenberg
inclusion initiative who put together
study to confirm that moving forward I
decided to make sure my press days were
more inclusive the majority shouldn't be
one type of person and she's not talking
about eliminating them from conferences
she's talking about adding more to let's
get more inclusion than she was that's
so when she said I'm not I don't want to
hear a 40 year old white dude about it
people have taken that to say I don't
want 40 year old white dudes to watch my
Captain Marvel movie that's not what
she's saying
what's additional context here yeah and
that's a tricky thing I feel like the
phrase white dude or white guy whatever
gets thrown around a lot in a very
vitriolic way there's a decent reason
for that on the one hand I do feel like
in a way if you look at the very big
picture there is validity but it does
also alienate a group of people and
sometimes people don't respond well to
the Hat I'm not trying to make an excuse
for these opinions because I don't think
that people are behaving the right way
about this when I see the response and
it seems like people are having these
very emotional reactions they're very
charged they're approaching this movie
though it's a matter of fact that it's
terrible or that it's got this agenda
and people haven't even seen it yet you
know that that says something to me the
people have gotten personally riled up
and are taking this whole thing
personally it's funny to me in the time
where we're having so many huge debates
about art versus the artists usually
surrounding you know some kind of crime
or a big problem but this is another
instance of that in in a sense to me a
very low stakes instance of that but
it's like she said this quote and
whether or not you like it and whether
or not you even taken the time to read
it to understand exactly where she might
have been coming from cuz that's also
important she just made a comment that
got misinterpreted that people don't
like people were up in arms about in
vehemently opposing this movie and yet
you know you can think of like worse
scenarios where people are very
apologetic about this like a Bohemian
Rhapsody or something like that where
there are people involved who have done
actually bad things and yet people are
bandying around this moving like we got
to take it down we got a bomb the
audience score and stuff like that and
it really is strange to me honestly and
it's disheartening you know and and it's
weird and I start to wonder what the
overlap is of people saying hey cut
louis c.k a break but [ __ ] brie like and
i'm not saying that everybody is like
that but i am curious as to if there is
overlap there because while it's not
maybe where your mind go is hearing
about this controversy it is a part of
that overall short verse asian double
guitar says it really seems to me the
people who stayed away from the drama
like this film or are being more honest
about what they think i wish more people
would do that the drama is wrecking
entertainment it's sad I liked a lot
about Cod from Marvel I enjoy it a lot I
would say that it's very true yeah and
as somebody who enjoyed this movie
authentically I am really ready for all
this to be done with so that I don't
have to think about Captain Marvel for a
while because the fun has been sucked
out you know is Issa I can already tell
by the light to dislike ratio that you
guys liked it isn't that ironic because
the second we said anything good dislike
started pouring him before he even had a
chance to get to the seven-minute mark
or I started talking about some like
negative criticisms about the film
it was already dislikes pouring in you
know when I saw the dislikes I said to
you when I was seeing what the hate was
for this movie I was saying I hope
people actually disagree with me I'm
brie Larson now before I was like yeah
there's that point where I was like I've
kind of worried that people are gonna
think I'm like sexist or something for
not liking brie Larson's performance and
then after seeing the way people are
being very sexist towards this movie I
said I actually hope people really
disagree with me now so I want to quote
George Blum here why does the guy on the
Left mean keep repeating his say many
things Brie's performance was too flat
he did this at least three or four times
if he wants to convince everyone about
his opinion man we got it you cannot see
his inner conflict I could see it
clearly at the end she's he starts
telling about the crazy weird stuff from
the movie that he hasn't seen another
MCU movie and the first half of the
movie she is not human has no memory
about her real life as a human and she
has blue blood the last court of the
movie that's changed dramatically for me
she was incredibly cute and funny even
in the first two quarters of the movie
absolutely stand for some brie Larson
and a great movie with my blowing visual
effects George I'm happy you really
liked her performance his common
response are obviously people who didn't
stay for the part where I talked about
brie Larson yes people who's saying that
how you know female propaganda I'm like
if this was a pushing female empowerment
thing on my end what I have really
talked about why I really didn't like
her performance the first time around I
watch this say you know like that just a
that doesn't make any sense guy like
that makes no sense if she's the main
female lead if I just had some agenda to
push where I was influenced or pressured
wouldn't I have praised her performance
yeah yeah like that's that a does it
makes sense and be know the movies good
I'd still recommend and I say that in
there spoiler I talked about how I liked
your performance more the second time
we're I'm happy to see people are
disagree in my opinion about brie Larson
I'm actually before though it was like
kind of worried about that now I'm like
[ __ ] disagree with me and help make
this movie a billion dollars you know
yeah well I don't know it's interesting
to go through all these comments for me
I can kind of start to at least pick
apart where people are coming from
because some people seem to be coming
from a place of hurt and frustration or
something like it seems like there's
something else driving some of these
comments rather than just a dispute over
the quality of a film and I think a lot
of people are riled up about the
comments that she made that were taken
out of context and so I think people who
gotten kind of charged over this movie
in a way that isn't altogether
constructive or necessary John paralysis
says one of two positive YouTube reviews
have seen out dozens of subpar to
negative ones interesting seems like one
must expect nothing to get something out
of it however Marvel has overhyped it so
much it would be hard to drop
expectations that's true a lot of this
does have to do with expectations it
seems like a lot of the response and
where some people are even criticizing
it or like people are saying it's just
fine people are saying it's just okay
when is what is just being fun good
enough oh we've given a lot of who
wanted this so many movies we've said go
see it just because it's fun fun is good
enough in most of the movies that exist
I recommended Aquaman for similar
reasons why I recommended this movie
these are two very different films as
opposed to comparing this to Aquaman are
very very different do i emotionally
connect with these films that are really
hard to heart level no not really but
there's so much fun so much visual
thrills to be had in this film lion and
this movie made me laugh a lot so yeah
that's why I would recommend it Rahel a
Bakke on says to be honest breed needs
just as Evans and Hembrough did war
movies to truly establish their
character and the post-credits scene and
cap tomorrow from from endgame Carol
nailed her line showed how she works
perfectly well with the other Avengers
see I I like that comment because one
thing I send the non-spoiler review I
didn't really care for Chris Evans the
first time around I really care for
Chris Hemsworth like I thought they were
both fine same way like that's kind of
how I am with brie Larson right now I'm
like she's fine you know she's cool I
really think that she's the kind of
character that under different direction
or a different movie or different story
allow her time today
these MCU movies are different they are
like the most expensive television show
you will have ever paid for it the way
hey you'll be like give the show a few
episodes trust me you'll like her I
really feel like one more movie with
brie Larson sure I shall nail this
character to that effect - there's so
many films in the MCU there's gonna be
another one in April like if you're yea
satisfied with this there's more yeah so
much more everything love your life says
it wasn't a bad movie the supporting
cast did a great job but brie Larson is
so damn robotic like what the [ __ ] I can
kind of deal with the feminism as it
wasn't overboard
it wasn't needed either though but
whatever I'm a big boy
man the MC is in trouble theater banking
larsen to be the face going forward she
was just very underwhelming and stiff
like she was always trying too hard okay
I get what he's saying I did have that
concern as well actually with brie
Larson being the fake like you they
struck gold with Robert Downey jr. being
the face of iron man to be told that
she's going to be the face of the MCU
moving forward honestly I'm kind of
there because that doesn't exactly
excite me for her to be the main face of
the image being one of the Avengers is
one thing but to be the main thing on
this way even though I do recommend this
movie as the standalone for the grants
the greater picture of it all know I'm
kind of there with you of I'm not
exactly excited for her to be but we'll
see what she does an end game you know
that's kind of where I'm at with that
yeah and I also don't exactly know what
they mean by that by her being the new
fake because the more these movies have
pressed on the more they've all become
giant ensemble pieces that are always
mixed yeah characters I doubt you're
just gonna get a bunch of solo brie
Larson movies rock is real music calls
the main lead in the movie boring I
don't think I said she was did I say she
was boring I don't recall seem boring
who's literally the Captain Marvel and
still proceeded to get positive reviews
about the movie the [ __ ] am I supposed
to do two cinema on Captain Marvel
herself is boring as [ __ ] I definitely
say she's boring as [ __ ] the thing was a
movie like this is there so much more
going for it than just Captain Marvel
there's a lot more going for it and
that's the main character who's a whole
bunch of things happening in the movie
it's kind of like how I felt with the
Iron Fist season - hey I'm like Danny
rands definitely not as good as everyone
else but there's a lot of other things
going on this season I really like it
you know it's a nuanced you know likes
parts work parts know and there are
times where she does really work for me
alright guys well that's it it's pretty
much covered everything hope you're
happy to be here please subscribe see
you guys later
you